[Musica]
salve benvenuti questo speciale
natalizio mentre guardate una poltrona
per due
mamma ho perso l'aereo mangiando
innocenti biscotti a forma di
orsacchiotto mi chiedevo quale potrebbe
essere i film di natale che recensirò
quest'anno la pagandone luridume
cinematografico me li sono passati sotto
mano alcuni di allara bellezza come
dimenticarsi per esempio di santa slay
in cui babbo natale che in interpretato
dall ex lottatore della wwe bomber
restano per non si dorme
dopo ore di incessante ricerca sono
finalmente riuscito a trovare il film
giornata l'iniziato tutti ex del 1989 e
diretto da jeffrey campbell guardandolo
fino alla fine mi sono chiesto perché un
film così carico di magica atmosfera
natalizia non venga trasmesso in tv per
esempio insieme agli speciali della
disney vediamolo insieme
il film inizia come ogni film natalizio
che si rispetti come un rito satanico
tre ragazzi cercano di creare tra di
loro un legame di sangue per distruggere
il natale match race con il motivo
perchè a loro il natale non piace motivo
originale mi stringi la durante il
processo da protagonista si tagliavano e
con il sangue evoca inavvertitamente
qualcosa
[Musica]
la c3 la percepite tutta la magia della
festività con questa mano che più finta
di così ci sono titone gigante da stadio
adoro a mandare tornata a casa
si scopre che il libro preso per il rito
appartiene al nonno che non la prende
bene ma è per me essendo che ometto
simpatico ne approfitto per presentarvi
la famiglia un anno in romanesco abbiamo
anche la palma stronza che le blocca la
carta di credito per essere uscita senza
dire nulla ai demonismo ai reni e il
fratellino cordone che la spia mentre si
fa la doccia
vieni a chi mi è basta
il padre invece è portò anni prima ma
c'è qualcuno nascosto nell'ombra pronto
all'agguato
[Musica]
lo chiedo perché non devo chiedere cosa
è successo la creatura precedentemente
evocata dalla ragazza attacca il
fratellino durante il sonno
oddio attacca sembra che gli stiamo
tanto in faccia e basta e come regalo
anticipato babbo natale ci porta un
pupazzo glorioso chi era proprio quello
che volevo
in tutto ciò viene incolpato il povero
gatto che passava di lì per caso
la mattina dopo la protagonista che
lavora come cameriere un centro
commerciale si lamenta della madre con
le amiche interessantissimo
nel frattempo uno vuole che assomiglia
vagamente a beppe grillo da giovane
cerca un lavoro
inutilmente
le tre grazie invece fanno la fila per
insultare il classico babbo natale che
parla ai bambini perché non hanno niente
di meglio da fare a quanto pare anche io
da piccolo avevo chiesto un impiego dopo
natale mi ha portato una felpa grazie la
l'intendo mania dilaga padre riprendere
il film ci mostra questo
poi mi spiego perché torniamo dalle
ragazze
sente sei bambini babbo natale il
maniaco sessuale bimbo se fossi te non
accetti di niente da uno così è non far
di giocare se ancora non riuscite a
sentire la magia del natale che questo
film sprigiona passiamo alla mamma e al
gatto
[Musica]
quella psicopatica della madre affoga il
gatto nell'acqua del vate e non so terra
in giardino buon natale a tutti
e siccome la follia non arriva mai da
sola il mostriciattolo entra nella
stanza del babbo natale maniaco e lo
accoltella di gli zebedei
[Musica]
lavoro come gli esca il sangue dalla
bocca nonostante la ferita i testicoli
ma di avere una faccia di cazzo non
contento tira fuori il gatto molto e lo
mostra la ragazza vive lo confusi
avete ragione vi sono arrivata addosso
una marea di scene stranissime prendete
un attimo fiato e rilassatevi
perché non avete idea dei colpi di scena
che arriveranno
il nonno sembra quello più interessato a
quello che sta succedendo qualcosa mi
puzza lo volevi prima viene preso come
sostituto al babbo natale maniaco e del
camerino dove è stato ucciso
vedo il simbolo incavato per terra la
notte sia beppe grillo sia le tre
ragazze hanno la stessa idea quella di
starsene chiusi nel centro commerciale
per motivi diversi ovviamente il vecchio
per starsene in pace a scoprire il
mistero del simbolo dei tre ragazzi
invece per vedersi con tre bei
fustacchioni ma qualcosa va storto
perché all'improvviso arrivano tre
uomini nero che iniziano a sparare
all'impazzata
[Musica]
fortunatamente il vecchio cerca di
aiutare la protagonista che dopo una
pistola nel bancone dei regali che mamma
perché regalare il solito libro di
ricetta vostra madre come potrebbe se
interessata non uso un accordo e 44
magnum a e un figlio che non la smette
di fare rumore inca della sua regalati
una compie 44 magnum e fallica gare
addosso sparandogli alla roma offerta
limitata langa sul vostro all'appello
questa è la classica scena dove
l'allievo il mostro di turno deve
confrontarsi con gli oggetti di tutti i
giorni degli umani in questo caso dei
giocattoli
solo che qui dura 3 secondi e non è
divertente grazie film ne avevamo
bisogno
[Musica]
oddio è avvenuto il miracolo del natale
questa scena appena ricordata nella
storia e non è finita
notate con che potenza di braccia che il
tela la povera malcapitata neanche una
tartaruga centenaria portati infarto
riuscirebbe ad attaccare così piano i
tre uomini meno se la svignano e il
vecchio riesce a salvare la protagonista
la riporta a casa e racconta tutto alla
madre compreso mostriciattolo a roma non
secchioni estensione smolders che tra
l'altro continuano a chiamare tron
esatto la madre finalmente dà la retta
alla figlia che vorrei tracks ma mi sa
di no mentre il vecchio fa in una
biblioteca a cercare di decifrare questo
vale detto sì
[Musica]
il nonno metti un crocifisso in una
pietà rossa piena di un liquido
misterioso se non so che cazzo stia
facendo ma sapete non gli anziani si
starà probabilmente annoiando ma ho
sentore di colpo di scena stari
supplementare e giappone
si no ditemi che è un parassita del
padiglione auricolare e che ho sentito
male ha sì un padre ha già paura
potevi scusarmi solo secondo
mi state dicendo che lì è nata da un
incesto tra quel belluno del nonno e la
simpaticissima madre
natale è la cosa peggiore è che non è il
colpo di scena più brutto
il vecchio incontro un professore che
può decifrare gli il simbolo e scoprire
il mistero della creatura
siete pronti al twist più disumano che
voi abbiate mai visto cose che neanche n
già ma che si fa una pena di multa rende
riuscirebbe a fare sentite qua i tre
uomini di prima erano dei neonazisti
[Musica]
lasciatemelo ripetere erano dei
neonazisti che hanno un piano quello di
creare una razza superiore per la
conquista del mondo per fare ciò devono
far copiare la creatura con una vergine
alla mezzanotte della vigilia di natale
in modo che rimanga incinta e faccia
partire la razza chiamata quarto reich
[Musica]
che cazzo sto guardando perché non mi
sono visto uno speciale natalizio di
vista il pd invece di sta roba qua
perché si sa dove
cosa faccio io sono sicuro che se
andassimo a casa di essere giappone in
questo momento li troveremo con ancora
le siringhe attaccata al braccio incesti
neonazisti tron riti satanici gatti
morti
sapete cosa basta anche questa nostra
per finire e io comunque devo sorbirmi
tutto questo bordello
no mi rifiuto adesso gliela faccio
vedere io gliela faccio vedere
caro babbo natale
[__] cordialmente ingiocabile
volete veramente sapere come va a finire
il film
ok ma lo faccio soltanto perché è natale
il vecchio viene intercettato dai
neonazisti che li mettono la bomba
dentro l'auto e la e banca solo
aspettare
[Musica]
makeba chicca sofà ma non poteva
semplicemente [__] l'abbuffata fine
stime invece di lanciarsi lui stesso in
corsa la madre incestuosa invece mentre
si fa un bagno vi è letteralmente fritta
come delle patatine del mcdonald's da
una radio buttata dal tron è il top five
dei big come se fosse ad un concetto
degli slayer finalmente il vecchio
arriva a casa della ragazza per salvarla
ed anche lui scopre la verità ma in tre
grinch arrivano e iniziano a picchiare
tutti il nonno che magicamente si è
pentito di tutto ovvio vuole salvare la
situazione
e un celio quando vedi che duri colpi di
pistola alla pancia non funzionano
tira su le navi per prenderlo a pugni
logico il nonnetto nazista c crepa
guardate questa scena qui il vecchio ea
terra che picchia 1 il secondo tira
fuori una pistola gli spara e il polmone
di botto c uccido stronzo sono porto e
il vecchio che simboleggiava un babbo
natale moderno muore è l'unico
personaggio decente crema
grazie la ragazza e il fratello porcello
scappano nella foresta di seguiti dall
ultimo nazistoide lencia minibook a lui
la raggiunge ma viene colpito da un
proiettile sparato
proprio l'altro
[Musica]
il crollo e le si avvicina e inizia a
flirtare con lei
[Musica]
il drone casanova il fratello intanto
torna a casa il vecchio magicamente
sopravvissuto gli dà la pietà con il
crocifisso per uccidere la creatura a
ecco a cosa serviva torna indietro da la
pietra alla sorella che c'è su santo non
ne ho idea
[Musica]
punto pare basta colpire la fuga da cui
è uscito uno schifo per il cinema
tutto qui la grande razza superiore e
ucciso da una pietra in una buca ma non
è ancora finita perché subito dopo si
inquadrano lei e il fratello sani e
salvi transizioni di movie maker ed un
feto un feto deforme jingle bells jingle
bells single man
quindi questo era uno scherzo
non ho mai visto una storia così
contorta specialmente per un film di
natale
ora mi faccia pendere un poster 50 x 50
in ufficio del feto finale che lo
scritto buone feste
spero che abbiate gradito questo
speciale io vi auguro buon natale
buone feste e tanti auguri per l'anno
che verrà
la non preoccupatevi i veri auguri che
ti faccio nel secondo canale prima della
fine dell'anno
da quest ultimo video del 2012 vi saluto
e ci rivediamo alle recessioni di
gennaio i regali bastardo